in five four three two son of a [ __ ]
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of genius brain podcast
how you guys doing chillin good I hope
you're doing wonderful because we are
doing fantasy I know it's been mad cold
in LA dude it was 40 degrees last night
it's funny because when we say that I
understand in Wisconsin Minnesota it's
negative 12
but LA we're used to 60-degree winters
and it is 40 degrees 35 degrees that's
super uncommon here and it's cold and
I'll tell you this right now I lost 60
pounds I shiver now my teeth chatter I
never had that before height challenge
Canadians and all these below zero
people to come down because yeah I have
a friend from Toronto uh and then you
know she was she was making fun of me
yeah for all the 40-degree 50° stuff
right yeah she came and visited one of
our winners uh-huh and she was like holy
[ __ ] it is cold here and the reason why
is because they acclimate to the cold so
so their days
don't become seventy where our days are
like 70 and at night it's like 40 or 50
yeah yeah yeah
so that dramatic drop is is is pretty
damn crazy so you go from walking around
with the t-shirt to at night you're
shivering even with like layers on so
that's what it is it's the it's the day
our bodies dramatically drop in
temperature dude I didn't even know
because the weight loss like how people
get cold so easy you're like a shivering
chihuahua now
yo that that [ __ ] that you learn in
what's it called like science about
bears and having fat and not being cold
is true in humans - I didn't shiver at
all dude if you go back to some of our
vlogs when we were in Japan Bart and I
were in a t-shirt sometimes and we were
chilling outside it was like 20 degrees
outside bro and we did not care we were
just walking around like it was cool
like it was all good and then now I'm
bundled up I'm wearing pants all the
[ __ ] time Wendy look at this [ __ ] bro
this is pants son yeah and then I don't
have the layer of protection I don't
like I'm wearing sweaters I'm wearing
sweaters and jackets on top of that [ __ ]
and I'm drinking hot tea I kind of like
the cold though I know now when I was
skinny as [ __ ] like 120 pounds mm-hmm
I'm a [ __ ] trembling Chihuahua man I
am NOT cool with that
I hated it dude I just wanted to stay in
bed all day there's this whole movement
now too with the cold showers and the
[ __ ] living in the cold there's
supposed to be like a health thing where
I'm supposed to be I'm just supposed to
be a lot of good benefits I guess a shot
of adrenaline I like hot showers I like
hot showers whether it's in winter or
summer me too I like burning burn my
skin I [ __ ] try to boil me man I feel
this because if I take a cold shower I'm
still dirty the grease don't come off
exactly I'm a greasy ass [ __ ] -
by the way greasy as hell if I don't um
take hot showers the grease doesn't melt
off yeah and I need that [ __ ] to melt
because I feel like it just stays in my
body and I start layering grease 100%
it's like I'm lathering my body with
lard and [ __ ] I've had um you know when
I went back to a Sacramento like I had
it's funny cuz I haven't seen my friends
in a minute right I haven't seen them so
long and they're so used to fat David
you know really it's been that long
since you lost weight and then you went
back up a whole year it's been a whole
yeah I admit back in a whole year and
yeah I don't I don't I don't really
think about stuff like that too much and
they're just like whoa you know you lost
so much weight and I think it's such a
shock for them because you know for a
majority of my life anyways you know a
few times where I flux that wasn't so
big yeah but it was it was a shock for
them and they they weren't they weren't
used to it you know I mean and I'm only
slowly starting to get used to it
sometimes like when I walk by a mirror
I'm like look what the [ __ ] you know
yeah I don't who's just skinny
[ __ ] yeah I mean I still got a
long way to go but you know that the
hell thing has helped out a lot for sure
shout out to Joe Rogan that bringing uh
what's-his-face David Goggins on is he
what he motivated you he's one of the
first he gave that spark back into it
and he helped me kind of put it in
reality and give me a reality check
right so the cool thing about David
Goggin is in his story it's about a man
who is not special doing special things
yeah
I feel like a lot of he was about to
yeah and people feel sometimes that you
have to be a specific type of person to
do certain things that other people are
doing and I think that's true in certain
cases and true and not in other cases
yeah dude totally because I I thought
for the longest time I thought I was not
aesthetic yeah I said I I'm not built
that way yeah I'm just not genetically
like but it it doesn't matter if you are
or you aren't like there's a lot of joy
that comes from being active it's it's
the same concept of when people who
don't want to go karaoke right they go
oh I can't sing that's not what karoke
was about it's not about singing there's
about making a fool out of yourself and
enjoying the moment yeah sing your heart
out yeah arguably if you sing worse it's
ten times better people love it it's way
better yeah you know nobody wants to see
somebody go out there and start doing
hella crazy runs yeah it's like shut up
you [ __ ] show off yeah like I'm not
going American Idol yeah when I when I
do karaoke I choose a Bruno Mars song
because I know I can't sing it a hundred
percent and it's ten times more fun that
way man I'm not trying to show people
how dope I am at this [ __ ] I'm trying to
have fun man it's all about performing
like you like you're just air guitaring
and [ __ ] like you're just doing it do
karaoke is like a huge part of Asian
culture man Filipinos Japanese and
Koreans we love karaoke to the max it's
like our biggest pastime you get drunk
you get a bunch of [ __ ] snacks and
foods and you just start singing your
ass off it's like guitar hero before
guitar hero oh that's exactly what it is
dude Filipino people always got that
microphone that's already built in with
all the buttons and they said it's cool
yeah and as like crazy reverb like you
could hear it from two blocks away and
the wor sound system attached to it you
know it's like it echoes like crazy
hello hello hello I have a friend of
mine who actually might bring on this
podcast she always tells me about her
dad her father was a performer in like
the Philippines like he was in
entertainment I think he did like
theater or singing or some [ __ ] and so
every time before they have a family
party yeah he practices before he gets
to carry all over them like he has to
get his sessions in before because I
might does like mama
like he practices he has a set list
before he goes up and does karaoke at a
family party because he might get
discovered he thinks like a agents gonna
be like oh my god I've been waiting for
this sound yeah like you'll come to LA
and he goes I have to go karaoke because
if I don't how am I going to get
discovered discovered I have to go out
there and people have to see my talent
but it's just among family and friends
yeah man and the guys is so [ __ ]
funny man like it's a talent show within
family karaoke is serious to him there's
a lot of people that take karaoke
[ __ ] serious though oh this is real
series that and like for Korean people
it's it's karaoke a church volleyball
plugin aggressive church volleyball dude
did you ever go to a Korean church
before I bet I visited some yeah yeah
every summer there's a couple of things
that happen dude I've been to some
summer camps and stuff but I never
played the games with them yeah so in
Sacramento they would do this thing I'm
not sure if they still do it now where
all the churches from all the Korean
churches in Sacramento would meet up and
have a volleyball tournament oh but it
was the most uncrushed like they ever
did because they would be cursing the
pastor's would be like dude I swear like
I'm just gonna kick this dude's ass like
let you just be thrown out the door when
it's time to win son like they will get
up set unreal dude they would be saying
like some unreligious [ __ ] to each other
Wow
I would crack the [ __ ] up it would take
you seriously so it would be like all
these denominations of Korean churches
that come across Batarian Baptist Church
is coming together but they're all like
it's so like one time out of the year
that's the only time they come during
the summer and then we would have our
church volleyball battles dance it's
almost like they're battling whose
denomination is better like Christ got
the Baptist is back there was a trophy
those trophies too maybe they got really
serious with it it's supposed to be like
a gathering of like fun no then it was
absolutely not they were talking mad
[ __ ] to each other dude have you guys
ever did camp meetings oh we did church
camp [ __ ] yeah yeah like but so like the
the the church I grew up was a seven-day
of Venice yeah and it's like there's a
lot of different races right yeah
like we'll have one that's like
everybody yeah that's like every race of
every church comes down and and then
sometimes they'll just be like a
Japanese one or like a Korean Won or
whatever but did you guys did you guys
come from on an organized group like
that or like um I don't know if we did
that where we did a lot of cultural
mixing just because we had half half the
church was people who couldn't speak
English
yeah so it was it was just more
difficult it was just difficult but did
your organization have like like a
committee and like a huge yeah so
Presbyterians have deacons yeah and and
make kind of and then you kick the money
all the way up yeah Catholic Church
right yeah and though they figure out
what to do with the money the funds who
gets but was it just one church or did
it have like national I don't think so I
don't think it was national you guys
were like independent independent I see
yeah yeah a seventh-day adventists I
like that it's net its worldwide dude oh
sure that's why George you know pink
dick George from jäger belly yeah he
grew up 7-day Adventist but we both have
very similar stories and upbringing and
stuff but he he grew up in like Virginia
or something but we know like there's
national universities like Loma Linda
University that medical school yeah
that's a seventh-day Adventist school
Oh for real yeah there's like I mean
there's like there's a lot of
universities private colleges schools
all over the country and so regionally
like we just have these things called
camp meetings and it's just like you
camp together and you worship together
and [ __ ] like that what is so what is
the what is the difference between a
seventh-day adventists and a traditional
like let's say a Presbyterian or or or
Baptists like Protestant well just
seventh-day at Venice I would say it's
more a little bit offshoot Christianity
like like how Mormonism and Jehovah's
Witness and you know they have a prophet
right yeah so in in that similar light
we have a prophet by the name of LNG
white well that is the most basic name I
know that [ __ ] threw me off right now
dude that is the most basic religious
name I've ever heard of my life dude LNG
white yeah it's a
it's a lady it sounds like she plays a
saxophone on Saturdays at a cafe really
like a jazz musician yeah my name is
Ellen G white and today we gonna place a
smooth ass jams in you baby yeah and
yeah I mean like you know how like the
Mormons or whatever they have their own
like person yeah I mean yeah but it's a
little bit different from I think
evangelical and Baptists and
Presbyterians they don't have like what
do you call it like I don't think they
have a prophet or they don't have a
person that is the leader leader right
what for well I mean like Lutheran has
like Martin Luther but it's just like a
renegade monk he's not like yeah yeah
yeah he didn't personally get like like
instructions from God yeah but like what
I mean by prophet is more like people
that that say they personally got
instructions from God and I'm like
Mormons Jehovah's Witness yeah there's
there's and in seventh-day adventists
and and there's like all these offshoot
Christianity groups yeah that has a
prophet that says that they have a
direct message from God so our prophet
prophet and I say our like because I'm
not a part of the religion religion but
what I grew up in Ellen so that's why I
refer to as our but they're like lmg
white she basically had vision like
dreams visions or communications from
from God himself telling her all these
other things and and and one of the
things is like trying to they're kind of
traditionalist and try it like purists
in the in a way of like being more
emphasizing the old Old Testament also
like in terms of like dietary stuff like
they're not eating bottom-feeding get
like shrimp and pork and yeah so they're
more I say like closer to Judaism
because they focus so much more in the
Old Testament there was the last more
ritualistic very ritualistic and then
also like she has her own things where
like I think one of them was
was like oh you got a you got to go
worship on the Sabbath yeah yeah yeah I
guess that's what God intended it to be
instead of a Sunday I think it turns
Sunday like like after the Roman
Catholics took over or something but I
don't know man there's all these other
things and rules but a lot of it is
rules a lot of it is there a lot of are
there all is there a huge Japanese
community within like the seventh-day
Adventists
well I don't know a single Korean
seventh-day adventists there Bobby I
don't know that many there are Korean
seven day Adventists though I know a
[ __ ] ton of Korean Jehovah Witnesses mmm
they would always come to my house and
my dad would invite them in and she was
less talk and they go now we're okay
because my dad you know he studied like
Christian theology and he you know he he
was a pastor yeah so he has a he has so
he they felt annoyed of him
Oh hundred percent cuz he was sit down
my mom would make a meal and they would
sit down and talk to each other ha god
damn what's up yo let's talk some Jesus
Christ homey
he's all excited yeah he's all trying to
compete it's like he's trying to
convince them to join his [ __ ] and it's
like we have to go say no no no please
sit down sit down I'm like you guys
[ __ ] up dude you came to the wrong
house my dad could talk for days about
this [ __ ] dude they got dude if you walk
into our house there's literally like
four bookshelves filled with just
Christian theology that he read whatever
reason pastor that's his thing right
down yeah let's [ __ ] wild man yeah
like I mean I think a huge part of
religion for immigrants to is community
building like mmm the like you know
before before the internet before like
cell phones and things like that right
yeah like yeah like the community was so
bonded and strong that like if you
needed to find someone within the church
you could find someone yeah cuz it's
like I mean some people grow up their
whole lives going to these private
schools within the church and all that
stuff yeah so like you know my mom has
lifelong friends and [ __ ] like that like
like yeah I don't know if I still have
like church friends anymore men like I
know I've connected with a lot of people
through church but I want to say there
are my closest friends anymore like I've
like the closest friends that I've had
I've met outside of church do you feel
like
well obviously you're still religious
yeah but do you feel like a disconnect
or like how do you practice your faith
basically I mean I still go to church oh
you do yeah like I said this before - I
got the body of Christ but the mouth -
Satan and I you know well Christ hung
out with prostitutes tasks tax
collectors and the filth of the earth
I'll represent that to the max yeah you
know you know it's weird you know
because people I know how I kind of see
religion is this it's like it's it's
individualistic - you know I just kind
of let people be like you know side that
whole thing of like you catch more bees
with honey than you do water and I can
only walk the walk - to Hawaii the best
I can do it and I still go to church you
know I get my refresher I try my best
you know I do get busy a lot and I'm you
know I'm out of town on Sundays so the
church that I go to is right around the
corner I'm trying to go maybe once or
twice a month and but you know I keep it
up I did listen to a lot of online
sermons and it keeps me grounded that's
that's the thing that I love about
church that it did for me maybe not for
everybody else I don't know you know but
for me it always keeps me grounded and
it humbles the [ __ ] out of me man yeah I
see like so many people their experience
is different yeah like you can't overall
blanket Christianity and say all over
the world these are gonna be the same
like you know like my anywhere is
completely different from yours yeah
and yeah I mean like I am no longer
religious in that sense but but it
doesn't keep me away from being a
spiritual person like I don't believe in
a higher being and I do believe like
like there's more meaning than just
being a human being that's existing yeah
but there's a purpose for us to you know
be kind and love one another and all
those things I think the things that I
grew up with the Christian values it has
stuck around it stuck around
yeah and in but then having a
relationship with a higher being whether
this entity is communicated through
Christianity or Buddhism or whatever
like I am not tied to one individual
religious group because at
end of the day it's a human being trying
to communicate or trying to explain this
connection they have with this spiritual
being
yeah and it's it's it's not in my
position or place so if somebody comes
out to me they go you know Christianity
is [ __ ] stupid and they call me
[ __ ] or something yeah I'm not gonna
sit there and debate with them about it
because I can't faith is just that it's
faith it is I can't I can't quantify
that's good that you don't take it
personal because only how do people take
it personal I can't take it personal man
like I can't because once again because
I believe it's individuos it's it
pertains to the individual I can't sit
there and debate with you on it because
number one it because your stuff is not
based on facts yeah it's faith based
yeah you're a hundred percent right bro
that's not faith it's not facts
mhm so I can't sit there and have that
argument with somebody and it's not
worth it either yeah my thing is to like
bro just don't [ __ ] on me for it and I'm
not [ __ ] on you for it don't be mad
at me I mean they probably had a shitty
experience and they're just taking it
out on you yeah there was when I became
atheist for a moment it was all just a
reaction to how I was raised Christian
style like it was me like that's my only
experience and how much um I have
personal resentment against my
individual Church yeah and the way that
they did things like but you know there
are other groups out there that are
doing great things and for me to not you
know like being young and just just
resenting the whole anarchy phase man
yeah yeah yeah like I get it and and
there are people that grew up in shady
situations where they got molested by
pastors or whatever right and then it's
like but that's the that's that's the
individuals that experience that's not
the whole religion is corrupt and [ __ ]
and those negative experiences too it's
I call it people are trying to find the
shoe that fits yeah you know they're
like well this is what I went through a
hundred percent you did yeah but you
can't just it's it's it's too easy to
condemn a whole group for that type of
stuff yeah you're gonna condemn billions
of people like seriously like they're
all guilty yeah yeah it's too easy to do
it that way man
um it's hard like I said it's gonna take
a lot of like personal soul-searching on
that kind of stuff man and you know that
we always talk about this - when it goes
back to that mental health stuff man
take that time for yourself and figure
that stuff out because if you're trying
to focus your whole life on hating a
whole group of people because of what
you experienced personally that's it's
not rough on them it's rough on you yeah
you know you're doing yourself a [ __ ]
disservice at this point dude because if
somebody looks at me and they go oh
you're Christian if I write man I can't
really change that I can't they're not
saying that about you they're saying
about the the people that try to force
religion down their throat yeah because
I would just be breathing in college and
just eating a [ __ ] sandwich and don't
be like Westboro guys come up [ __ ]
telling you God hates [ __ ] or like
there's a like they used to come and
pick it our school yeah they'll be like
[ __ ] you know like Christian club kids
that are inspired to just spread the
word of God but they're so forceful and
it's socially weird the way that they do
it in Riverside - there was this dude
that was on campus that had a huge like
uh but I mean huge I mean [ __ ] big
man and if you guys went to Riverside
you know in like Oh 607 you know this
dude that had this huge picket sign and
it had a huge sign that says like [ __ ]
or what a fact I think was like [ __ ]
sodomites are all gonna burn burn in
hell screaming that [ __ ] man and I
always looked at this dude like what are
you trying to accomplish yeah when you
say that do you really think that you're
helping somebody like someone's gonna go
oh really
well thank you for telling me that cuz
now I had no [ __ ] clue that I was
gonna go to hell but now I know thank
you
that's like I wish I'd known it before I
was [ __ ] somebody yes yesterday it's
like oh man
it'sit's wild man um and I used to see
that [ __ ] and as a kid that grew up
Christian I never understood it I never
ever understood it I didn't get it I'm
like yo man what are you trying to prove
right now they're just crazy yeah some
crazy-ass peaceful fanatic it's just
fanatical dudeney they they're really
like the the minority here and the bad
apples because for the most part like
people use religion as a way to just
come together
Connect hangout learn life lessons
socialize
I had a there's this group called K CCC
korean Christian Crusaders for Christ or
something like that hey yo this is a
huge organization like a college campus
organization that's all over different
you know and there was another group
called KCM I believe Korean Christian
ministry or campus ministry and so it
was funny because the you would see
their booth right s'okay trip que si si
si I'll be it at the time from the one
that I experienced it was a lot of like
if you just looked at them you know the
greasy-haired we'd be kids yeah very
nice very sweet
you know just down-to-earth like chill
people and now on the other side there
was KCM these [ __ ] over here
with us with a soju bottle smoked a
cigarette you guys both Christian you
know and they would try to recruit like
Korean people or whatever and they were
so they were so different in their
approach and so when I went to I went to
que si si si si because I didn't really
vibe with the case yeah well they just
seemed like a bunch of posers yeah
that's some tough guys and [ __ ] ya guys
are [ __ ] Christian group dude chill
chill the [ __ ] out there like we love
God but we smoked cigarettes yeah like
we're bad like on so tip like that right
they just seemed like they were out to
prove something that they weren't so I
was like you let me check out this case
Triple C [ __ ] whatever a gospel thug
yeah I believe in God homie but I'm
still gonna bang homie yeah I was to be
honest with you there's a lot of dudes
like that there are a lot and then um I
went to this que si si si Bing and so
there was a girl named Ann Marie she was
a Filipino girl and she was she was in
my dorm and we went there together
and we went to a sermon or whatever and
afterwards she was exhausted and she
kind of leaned her head on my shoulder
right we're chillin and this guy comes
up and he goes hey man uh we don't do
that here I was like do what I was like
she goes oh you guys can't do like
public affection stuff here I was like
public what do you mean public affection
like we're not together she's just tired
she's just resting her shoulder or
resting her head on my shoulder she goes
yeah but you know that's not very you
know christ-like and I was like and I
thought you know there's this doing it
that's not exactly yeah
I was very confrontational at this point
at this age so you're just like I just
said I was like show me in Scripture
you showed me a scripture where it says
that this is wrong show me right now I
think that's the biggest thing I have
against religion yes people use it as a
way to kind of force their own ideals
that has nothing to do with Scripture
yes and then they make it seem as if if
you challenge them that you're
challenging God yes so I think that
that's true for whether it's Buddhism or
Islam or whatever there's a lot of
self-righteous people that don't know
the difference between preference and
culture and morals that like they like
their truck just pressuring other people
to follow and if you challenge them
you're challenging God and I hate I
absolutely hate that that's why I don't
run away from the church it was so weird
because I didn't understand what they
meant and so that K CCC group that one
individually like I don't know how it
was on other campuses but that campus if
you were up going to be a part of KCC
see I think like in the first two years
of your college experience they told you
that you weren't allowed to date well I
I don't [ __ ] know or I'm not sure if
you weren't allowed it was something
about it was scorned apart apart so they
promote like celibacy yeah but that's
not even Celebi said you can't be in a
relationship or date in the first two
years almost like what and part of the
Bible that it saved that where like
you're creating your own rules
yeah that's what I don't understand yeah
like this is so it was such a weird
concept for me and yeah that was my
first taste of I don't know if I like
this religion anymore but then I started
to realize that I was I was judging the
religion that I grew up with based on an
individual's actions you know and I
wasn't looking at the personal
relationship that I had with whatever my
faith in God yeah you know so I had to I
had to learn that lesson the hard way
because during that point point of
college like you I stopped going to
church because that experience yeah it
made me I mean that's I'm right there
with you man I used to keep going to
church and my parents stopped going yeah
and then I would get taken to church by
other church members so I could still
keep going going and see my friends and
stuff but like mm-hmm I you know the
older you get you start waking up to
certain things and you start asking
questions
yeah like I
roughly so you should yeah but the but
but when I ask questions out of
curiosity I was treated as if I'm just
being argumented you talking [ __ ] about
Jesus homie yeah dude
and I'm just I'm just curious cuz I like
to think and I like to talk and I like
to figure things out right like and one
of the things was like I was told not to
mingle and mix with people outside of
the church even yeah even Sunday
worshippers cuz they're they're
corrupted by the devil and I was like
there's a lot of genuine people that
exist in this world that are not
Christian yeah and I was like there's
Buddhists out there there's there's
other people out there that I love that
are my friends
some are family members that are that
aren't 7 day event is yeah how come
they're condemned just because they
don't go to church on Saturday and I
said that and then they're like you're
being like trouble you're being
blasphemous yeah and I'm like no answer
the [ __ ] question that's what I was
thinking in my head is like answer the
question and I realized as a little kid
I was like 13 at the time or 14 I was
like I was like man they don't know the
answer I was like they they they feel
the pressure from me just asking a
simple question cuz they can't think and
they're too damn dumb because they
didn't question it themselves exactly so
when they're confronted with that
they're like holy [ __ ] how do I answer
let me see the bolts and steam come out
their head yeah but you should be able
to talk openly and freely in question
things that's why that's cuz I like that
that should make your relationship with
your relation religion stronger the more
people give you questions and the more
you can answer it openly and honestly
right but I just didn't go to a church
that can do that yeah I I think I went
to a church that was the opposite of
that like they we had a lot of guest
speakers that came in and there was a
guy named a pastor Alex he was like this
traveling pastor and even he was talking
about
not so much questioning your religions
but ask questions because there's gonna
be times where you're you are gonna
doubt your religion but if you don't
explore that and you don't come back
from that then your faith wasn't that
strong in the first place so it is I
think it is up to you to question your
religion and half questions and you have
them answered that's why I kind of feel
like what I went through is a little bit
of a cult you son of a [ __ ]
don't you dare quash it you know yeah I
mean like think about it dude most were
encouraged to go through the private
school system of the church yeah
associate and hang out with only members
of the church yeah marry within the
church huh everybody outside is tainted
like that demon sounds like some cult
[ __ ] cuz mmm ha is love everybody and
bring everybody together but it's like
bring on everybody under the religion
that doesn't make sense right it's like
if you do have love for everybody and if
God says unconditional love love your
enemies love your neighbour everything
is about unconditional love love the
people that you hate whatever if that's
true then you shouldn't be like well
only my seventh-day adventists and
everybody else [ __ ] you guys you know
yeah yeah yeah like cuz you guys are
going to hell and I'm not you know like
what is that there's some interesting
things too like I've kind of noticed
that a lot especially in a lot of mega
churches in LA cuz I you know I shopped
around for different different churches
to see which one I liked yeah and I I
found something very fascinating dude
Church is too depending on which one you
go to some of it's just a [ __ ]
business man
it's it's a big business [ __ ] huge
multi-million dollar business give me
money and I'll make you feel better
that's all it is yeah it's it's it was
so different from the churches that I
grew up in you know and that's the
reason why I'll be it they probably
struggled financially because they were
they were focused more on the teachings
of the religion and they were about
grabbing people and for their money and
which is what I grew up with so when I
came to LA that was another big test
that I had I was like damn [ __ ] these
churches man but money grubbing says the
[ __ ] why are these [ __ ] pastors
talking about like I'm trying to help
people out but you got a multi-million
dollar mansion dude well it makes
because they they basically
enable and make a lot of the greedy
people feel good about themselves yeah
cuz they're like they're like yeah you
know you deserve that expensive car you
deserve this and that don't oh yeah yeah
and then they feel good so they give
more offering because they feel like
they're giving to God too because deep
down inside they do feel good read or
whatever it is I'm used to like the
pastor's that I grew up like even my dad
right so might when my dad started
started up a church in Sacramento
because we had our own business he was
wanted like the Deacons there and he
started up that church with one of his
close friends he didn't take a paycheck
from the church dad at all ever and
that's how it should be yeah cuz he had
his own source of income yeah and we
weren't even rich either it's not like
our family couldn't have used it yeah
you know but my dad did it and he worked
at that church tirelessly and I really
respect that about him and a lot of the
other peoples of the church all those
deacons like I really respected that out
of them you know and so when I saw the
opposite that happened in some of the
you know I'm not saying they don't work
hard but I it always made me feel weird
when I saw yo be making seven figures is
definitely living beyond your regular
means well I don't think a pastor should
ever make seven figures yeah I believe
that they could they should make a good
living because they are doing all [ __ ]
ton of work but seven figures I mean
when it comes to religion I personally
just have it makes me feel weird about
rock star religious people yet they're
rock stars that's what they are they
start to become these rock stars because
they're too powerful yeah they're not to
me I feel like they're not servicing the
the higher peoples I mean the hot the
Spears he's like they're servicing
themselves exactly mmm they're basically
sucking their own [ __ ] dick they're
taking the attention away from the
spirits I I saw this too and it was so I
went to this church and I was so curious
because so there was a person that in
the crowd that asked so it within the
Protestant religion homosexuality is a
sin right so stealing and all that other
stuff right and this person asked the be
pastor this is what he says he goes so
what what is the Christian belief on
homosexuality and what is your opinion
on it right and he goes is is it a sin
or is it not and he's in the Bible it
says it's a sin
he didn't say that though oh this is
what he said he goes there are people
who were gay that come to this church
and I love them too and you know I have
I grew up with a you know some people
who are gay and he was like why can't he
just admit that it's a sin he wouldn't
do it because I would have just been
like yes it's a sin just like lying is a
sin which we all do so we all live with
sin so he was I I was like what is he
wait hold on a second what is he doing
and then he and they asked again and
this person said to this pastor he goes
that's not what I asked they go what is
what I'm asking is what what is your
opinion and what does the church say
about it he goes goes back to it again
beats around the bush well you know I've
had homosexual people come up to me and
say that they love this church and the
person was like yo basically he's making
a big uns thing I don't want to lose my
customers that's what he was saying I
want to lose my customer I lost so much
respect for him dude because no matter
whether I agree or disagree with what he
was gonna say as a religion you should
have a stance yeah or as anybody with
the serve have a [ __ ] stance dude and
be able to defend it or or not even
defend it just you or you weren't
worried about you what your beliefs were
you were worried about losing your
customers right and I was like holy [ __ ]
this is a business
boom boom moment for me dude and I I
looked at this pastor saying like you
could have just said yes it's a sin in
the religion but we're also a faith
about love and everybody's welcome here
man mm-hmm
everybody's welcome here like you're
welcome here you know let's list all of
you who hasn't like everyone broke
something in the Bible yo man I'm
breaking [ __ ] all day yeah and they
haven't even even thoughts about sinning
is actually a sin itself yeah it's like
so I mean who is without sin like I mean
and why can't you just admit that it is
yeah why can't you say it before
marriage is it lying is a sin like
everything that we do is already a sin
within the religion yeah and I I gotta
say to like I can't even in that I can't
judge every church for for that what
that guy did I can't say every church is
like that even though this is not this
is not a nebulous statement or a comment
I'm just saying what I saw made me feel
a certain way about this church and
which is why I left
yeah because I felt like people and also
at this church they talked about tithing
way too much so you knew it was the
business when they passed the offering
table more than one time during a sermon
I'm just like this is not nice dude the
dude talked about tithing I think like
nine out of ten times I was there God
like bro we get it you want 10% of the
[ __ ] paycheck I [ __ ] get it can
you get to the [ __ ] sermon dude like
that's what it was constantly about you
know what I do like about mega churches
though they are entertaining as oh they
got murdered
yeah they got like angels flying from
the sky and [ __ ] they got flown back
video of that dude [ __ ] cable coming
down floating yeah and then he'd be spun
back around and [ __ ] dude I've been to
one word there's like basketball cords
yeah there's like swimming pools there's
it's just so fun man the [ __ ] Korean
church that I went to as a kid yeah we
used to play ball it was at this back
area at the church slot that had weeds
cracked but there was no basketball net
yeah rusted his [ __ ] at that place they
tore that [ __ ] down and they built a
[ __ ] basketball court indoor
basketball or my god how much money that
church has now Dan where the [ __ ] was
that when I was a kid dude well they
changed her business practices right but
I mean anything see that's that's a huge
part for me when it comes to religion
it's like it's like I feel kind of sick
in the way that people get taken
advantage of yeah so a lot of people
join religion because you know they're
lonely they're hurt they're they need
help and they might receive some type of
community warmth and and and stuff that
they mean through religion but there are
a lot of people that take advantage of
that power and of that experience
because there's corrupt human beings
exact people aren't perfect you know and
I you know to the credit of you know
Christianity that I've been a part of
yeah I've learned a lot from it as a
human being yeah and I think that too
that religions credit it did help mold a
lot of values in my life that I still
keep till this day like I definitely
don't think I would have been Who I am
today without it in terms of a lot of
the positivity and there's a lot of
great memory
is that you bill like community the
sense of belonging the sense of giving
is what I received back from
Christianity was in what you're supposed
to do in this world the sense of purpose
yeah and I think a lot of those things I
hold on to till this day there's
definitely a lot a lot of negativity
from human beings yeah
but yeah I mean because it's so
prevalent everywhere you go I went
through this journey where I try to look
for a good church and all that stuff
and it's it's full of so many stupid
people then I'm just like I can't do
this man yeah it's hard I don't there's
no perfect Church really there's no
perfect group yeah wherever you go
there's gonna be politics in drama and
stupidity because a lot of people are
stupid yeah yeah right so sometimes it's
just better to have a spiritual
connection with you and your beliefs and
keep it separate from kind of dogma or
institutionalism and just like groups
I've learned one of the things that I
learned that I still keep till this day
that my dad taught to me as well which
was a part of like it's giving a
wholeheartedly like if you're going to
give something to somebody don't expect
something in return
yeah and I always love that [ __ ] when I
when I lent out money to people it was
always because I gave it to them because
I didn't expect that to be returned back
to me wow that's a real Dan you real
real christ-like right now felt like
Judas bro who's that tax collector was a
Judas I forgot it was a disciple but it
was Judas oh yeah yeah I'm just playing
yeah but then I I wanted to because it
also strains like Rick relationships
right so if somebody came up to me in my
dude this is I'm not saying that I'm
screening the person that's asking for
the money to like I know who this human
being is right so I know this person is
trying hard I know that they're going
through issues where they need to borrow
money and yeah I'll do it you know
they'll come up like you know I mean
five hundred bucks and it's hard for
them is I can see them just just it just
like it's hard to push it out their own
[ __ ] teeth to ask them some money and
I give it to them and I'll pay you back
I'm like sure go ahead if whenever you
want don't even worry about it
and after that is out of mind out of
sight and you don't collect no know if
they
you pay me back thank you very much like
I have a friend right now like arguably
I probably led to him a total of like
maybe three or four grand over the
period of like our friendship I didn't
expect that back and I was backing to
give it back to me yeah he's going
through his own stuff he has his own
journey and when you maybe one day maybe
you'll get you'll learn and then he'll
you know and if he doesn't know yeah but
you know I had I had the financial
stability to lend that money out and
still be okay okay yeah so that's what I
think about what's the time you know how
long were we talking for it was 40
minutes so let's just call it the
religion one I gotta pee really bad so
we could just it's go ahead go be okay
yeah you want to end it really quick and
it will cut it and just call it the
religion one yeah so if were for like
these things to like in the in the
future that you don't have to stop like
that cuz I want this to go all the way
through okay just decide to end the
podcast wherever you want okay just go
like alright guys so yeah so you got a
minute
okay I'll be in and end it yeah okay
guys this was a really really awesome
episode but I gotta pee so bad and I
think we covered a lot about religion
and and we never really got this deep
about gianna tea and our personal
experiences so I think it was really
good because a lot of people were asking
us how he felt and what our personal
experience was cuz there's a lot of
people out there that are religious and
sometimes I think they feel attacked or
they feel like kind of weird when I talk
about how I left the church and stuff
like that yeah which it has nothing to
do with your guys's experience or or
anything it's not a personal attack it's
not right or wrong yeah it's just that
was you know my choice and what I went
through
well that's pretty much it but thanks
for joining us on this episode of genius
brain I gotta pee so bad so I'll talk to
you later peace